hello everyone i'm prime nataranjan
i'm a vice president in the alexa ai
organization
leading conversational ai areas
such as dialog systems natural language
understanding
and related technologies i'm here with
my colleagues the lake hakane tour
and arundham mandal we're here to talk
with you about the
alexa prize about our overall
collaborations and partnerships with
academia
and also to introduce the winners of the
alexa prize socialbot grant challenge
3 which is the third annual round of the
competition
delek hi i'm dilekka kanitor
i'm a researcher at amazon lxai
and i lead a science team focusing on
machine learning based
approaches for building better
conversational interaction systems
hi i'm arinda mandel uh i'm a director
here in alexa ai
leading several programs in the area of
conversational ai to advance the science
and build
delightful experiences for our customers
at amazon we strongly believe that
solving the hardest problems in ai
especially conversational ai requires
bringing together
the talent that's based in academia and
in
industrial research labs to that end
we have created a number of programs
that are designed
to facilitate collaboration with
academia
our flagship program is the amazon
scholars program
which allows researchers and faculty
members at top universities worldwide
to come work at amazon address some of
our
hardest customer facing challenges and
then see
the advances that they make in action
impacting our customers lives a second
program
is the amazon research awards program
which provides
funding in the form typically of
unrestricted gifts
and also aws compute credits for faculty
and researchers
to continue advancing their own research
areas
uh making new inventions and also
funding the work of their phd students
but of course today we're here to
largely focus on the alexa prize
arundham you've been here during all
three years of the alexa prize right
from the start
i think it'd be interesting to hear your
perspective on how it got started
and how it has evolved over the past
three years
thanks frame back in 2016 when
alexa was a nascent voice assistant at
amazon
we wanted to spur invention in this area
so we started alexa prize as a form of
collaboration
with universities and our vision was
that such advances would be a rising
tide that would lift all boats in the
conversational ai ocean
over the years more than 40 university
teams have participated in the price
challenge
and we have increased our funding we
give them 250 000
per team access to state-of-the-art
infrastructure through amazon web
services
access to world class speech recognition
national language understanding and
dialogue management capabilities
so that student researchers can build
chat bots for
the grand challenge what's particularly
interesting and unique about this
competition is that student researchers
at universities
get direct access to our end users and
learn from their feedback to improve
their chatbots
thereby being able to
advance the state of the art in almost
real time
this was unthinkable for many of us
at least for me when i was in grad
school
we look forward to inventions from the
universities
in areas of natural language
understanding language generation and
dialogue management
through the alexa price program uh delek
you have been part of the conversational
ai community for a very long time
uh you've made substantial contributions
uh of your own
um what i find exciting about the alexa
prize
is that it accelerates academic
invention
by breaking down the barriers to
large-scale
real-time feedback from real users
real-world conditions i'm curious to
hear about your perspective
on what you have found exciting about
the work done by the different teams
in this round and about the prize
overall
thanks prem all the teams actually made
the advances
in multiple areas of dialogue modeling
throughout the program
and i think it's amazing how
so many teams has been eight to ten
teams
throughout the different years of the
challenge
in coordination with alexa customers can
actually
influence impact conversational ai
research in such an interesting way some
of the
advancements that the teams made include
using of structured and unstructured
knowledge
for better conversational responses
entity recognition entity linking
modeling of conversation context
understanding of users emotions their
sentiments towards
topics and entities and producing
empathetic responses in in return
and and many areas of conversational ai
if i focus on the top three bots uh
emory university's amara team they
analyze the impact of
conversations about personal experience
on customers and how the customers are
perceiving
uh these conversations as as engaging
they experimented with systems producing
opinions and not just facts
they also analyzed the impact of opening
conversations with
current events for example holidays uh
covet and so on uh
stanford university's chirpy cardinal
team
explored use of textual resources
unstructured text
such as wikipedia to form responses like
other teams
but they also employed a neural network
based approach to make systems responses
more conversational rather than just
reading the text
and they also attempted to generate more
empathetic responses
uh uh on personal or emotionally charged
topics
uh using the public the available
empathetic dialogues data set
and they train neural network models to
generate these responses
uh czech tech universities all quest
system is based on
a very large conversational graph and
adjacency pairs where
adjacency pairs are small conversational
templates
grounded by a knowledge graph and these
could be stitched together to make
a longer and interesting conversations
okay thanks and now on to the most
exciting part
presentations and talks from the teams
themselves thank you
hello everyone and welcome my name is
james finch
and i'm sarah finch sarah and i were
co-team leads for emory university's
team that competed to build
the most engaging chat bot in this past
year's amazon alexa prize
in this video presentation we'll be
sharing the design and principles behind
our social bot
emera as well as the scientific
takeaways of our work
our team consisted of a combination of
graduate and undergraduate students from
two
emory labs the intelligent information
access lab headed by professor eugene
agenstein
and the natural language processing lab
headed by our team's advisor
professor geno choi
as with any alexa prize team our goal
this year was to create a chatbot that
can engage users in casual conversation
on a variety of topics chatbots in
previous years could discuss many topics
like movies
sports and recent news however we notice
that one major focus of current work in
dialogue systems
is on information oriented chat where
dialog agents utilize a bank of world
knowledge to pull relevant phrases or
responses from
this seems to be at odds with human
human dialogues where people spend the
majority of their time discussing their
personal experiences
life events and opinions so our main
goal this year was to make strides
towards a more socially oriented
conversation between humans and machines
this meant creating a bot that could
talk about more than just facts and
information
and focused instead on sharing opinions
experiences and feelings
we want people who talk to emira to feel
understood and appreciated
as if talking to a friend
to illustrate the unique design of emra
we make a distinction between three
types of dialogue
information oriented dialogues focus
primarily on objective
question answering and talking about
factual knowledge
opinion dialogues might also contain
lots of factual information
but are more concerned with the
converser's preferences thoughts and
reactions to that information
finally we define experience-oriented
dialogues to be primarily focused on the
conversor's own
lives relationships and experiences
here's sarah demonstrating the
difference
between these three dialogue types while
talking to our bot emira
starting with an information oriented
interaction
okay i guess that you like action and
adventure movies
correct yeah i do
awesome i am so smart hey
i have found a great action and
adventure movie which is in the theaters
right now
it's called bill and ted face the music
would you like me to tell you about it
yeah sure go for it bill and ted face
the music is a comedy and action movie
starring keana reeves and alex winter
directed by dean pariso
with rating 79 out of 100 according to
rotten tomatoes
it premiered on august 27 2020 do you
want to know plot of bill and ted face
the music
here's an example of an opinion-oriented
conversation
okay tell me what was the last movie you
liked
i mean i just watched interstellar again
so that one was pretty cool
interstellar is it the one with matthew
mcconaughey and anne hathaway
i really think it is underappreciated i
love i am robot with will smith
robots become self-aware and live among
humans as equals
what a life tell me why do you like
interstellar
honestly the entire plot i just found it
so fascinating
and finally here's an experience
oriented interaction
which we hypothesize to be the most
engaging conversation type
i understand it can definitely be
stressful
what would you change about your school
if you could
i mean i wish the course requirements
were a little bit different
but other than that it's it's okay
right i totally agree are you in any
school clubs
or anything like that i'm actually a
part of the math
team cool your school has a group for
math
what is it like we get together and
learn how to solve problems more quickly
and then we travel around
like during the year and compete against
other schools
sounds like a good time the boundaries
between these three categories are not
clear-cut
but the definitions are still useful and
it's pretty easy to agree on most
classifications
as the competition progressed it became
clear to us that information-oriented
interactions were fundamentally less
engaging to our broad population of
users than opinion and experience
oriented ones
the left-hand bar graph shows the
average user rating when opening
conversations
with either an information or
opinion-oriented version of our
coronavirus topic
when emra talked with users about their
thoughts worries and expectations during
the covet 19 outbreak
users gave significantly higher ratings
than when emira instead focused on
information about the virus such as
infection statistics the right hand
graph compares opinion oriented and
experience oriented dialogue strategies
unlike in the left-hand analysis we
didn't create two versions of a
component to compare
opinion and experience oriented
conversation since doing so requires a
lot of developer effort
instead we prototyped conversation flows
to talk about the user's work or school
in an experience oriented fashion and
compared the performance of these new
topics
against four of our existing opinion
oriented topics
although making a comparison between
different topics is a potential confound
we believe that the strong performance
of our experience oriented components
despite their short development time is
indicative of an underlying causal link
between experience oriented chatbot
design and user engagement
now we'll move into the technical design
of emra emera was deployed and hosted on
aws ec2 servers during the course of the
competition
we used the conversational bot toolkit
provided by amazon
to automate the deployment process of
our bot's components and the creation of
the appropriate auto scaling policies
this allowed our bot to adjust its
resources to handle variations in user
traffic
with minimal impact to its response time
our system architecture follows a
traditional pipeline design
where the user utterance is first passed
through a series of natural language
processing modules
before control is handed to the dialog
manager to generate a system response
the natural language processing modules
allow for specific features to be
extracted
based on the user input which then
becomes available to be accessed by
later parts of the system
in addition to receiving the user
utterance and its extracted features
when generating the next system response
our dialog manager also had access to
contextual information from earlier
interactions in the dialogue through the
state table
user information saved and stored in the
user table from previous conversations
and knowledge bases that we had crawled
into the amazon relational database
and elasticsearch services
the automatic speech recognition and
text-to-speech modules of emra
are those that are used by other amazon
alexa skills
as a result our socialbot received a
list of n best hypotheses for the text
transcription of the user's utterance
but we did not have access to any actual
audio input
similarly we were able to modify certain
acoustic elements of our system's
response
using the amazon speech synthesis markup
language
but the final translation from text to
speech was conducted by amazon alexa
speech synthesizer
we had a few main focuses when
extracting features within our nlp
pipeline
first we used a topic and intent
classifier in order to classify
utterances into their most related
topics
things like movies or sports and to
assign the most likely purpose
underlying the user utterance
like whether they were requesting
information or indicating their
agreement
our classifier was a combination of the
amazon provided topic and intent
classifier
as well as our own custom deep learning
classifiers that we trained on our
internal conversation data set
from our 2018 competition bot
our custom classifiers were intended to
supplement edge cases
that were underrepresented by the amazon
classifier in our bot's interactions
second we used the amazon provided ev
question answering service
in order to retrieve information related
to the user's utterance
and then we also use some additional nlp
models for understanding user input
such as spacey's named entity recognizer
and the vader sentiment analysis
provided in nltk
the core decision logic of emra is based
on a simple state machine approach
which we extend to improve flexibility
and robustness
each state encodes a different point
within our conversation flows
and the transitions between states
enumerate either the possible user
utterances
or system utterances depending on who is
expected to speak next
we used our custom state machine
framework emra stdm
to develop our dialogue manager mrastdm
allows for the flexibility to use
handcrafted rule-based transitions
or transitions that are defined and
classified by machine learning-based
models
within this state machine formulation
the transitions corresponding to user
utterances
act as a classification of the user
utterance into one of many predicted
user responses for the state
we define complex language templates for
different response types that we want to
handle for each state
and then create the corresponding
transitions
there are often several user transitions
from each state as there are frequently
more than one valid response to a
different
dialogue situation and these user
transitions are shown in purple in this
diagram
to allow for smooth unexpected response
handling we also encode one of the user
transitions for each state to be an
error transition
and this error transition is matched if
the user gives a response that does not
match any of our other predefined
transitions
for a system utterance the transition
denotes the natural language response
that the system outputs when in that
state
examples of system transitions are shown
in green here
for most states there is a single system
transition
although we also frequently injected
diversity into our dialogues
by allowing for multiple system
transitions from a single state
during a system turn beginning in a
state with multiple system transitions
a single one is randomly selected as the
final system response
although the state machine design on its
own works well for defining localized
conversation exchanges
for a truly coherent and engaging
dialogue there's also the need for
tracking conversation level information
and for transitioning in a global way
such as for things like topic switches
to this end we used a hybrid dialogue
management model
that augmented the state machine
approach presented in the last slide
with an update rule table inspired by
the information state approach to dialog
management
the information state approach was
coined by larsen and trump
in the early 2000s and presents a
theoretical framework of how
dialogue information is updated over the
course of a conversation
in emra's design a memory table is
maintained that can track things that
the user mentions
such as their name or their favorite
movie and with this in place
before the state machine executes a
transition the update rules can impose
some effect on the memory table
or even on the current system transition
options given that certain preconditions
are met
as you can see our dialogue management
approach is primarily rule-based
which has the limitation of poor
generalizability to new dialogue domains
despite this limitation the high degree
of explainability and controllability of
this approach
suited our goals in the competition to
explore the potential of
experience-oriented conversation
we really needed the ability to rapidly
prototype a variety of conversation
designs with many specifications
which were often not represented well by
any data set
our approach supports this rapid
prototyping workflow
and it is also flexible enough to allow
seamless integration of machine learning
models
whenever we needed a boost in
performance to understand user input
now that we have covered the overall
goals and technical design of emra
we want to share some key elements of
emra's interaction design that were
driving factors in emra's success
one of these design elements was emra's
ability to personalize the conversation
to each user she talked to
as emra talks to someone she saves
information shared by the user into a
user profile
this user profile contains information
such as the user's hobby
their favorite movie or whether they go
to school
once certain information about the user
is known emra can prioritize
transitioning to a topic for further
discussion
in this way amorous conversations can
vary depending on who she's talking to
and these user-tailored interactions
help users feel like she truly
understands them
here's sarah talking to emra again this
time demonstrating emera's ability to
personalize the conversation to a user
oh i love a friendly cat what is your
favorite thing about her
she's always so energetic and really
likes to play with the toys that we get
her
yeah that's a good one does your kitten
have a special bond with anyone in
particular in your home
like you or your partner or something
she's always following my husband around
so i would say probably him
it sounds like your husband and her have
a special relationship
that must be really heartwarming to
watch
oh yeah and he really loves it too for
sure
well one thing that gets my dog super
excited is when we are watching a movie
and an animal comes on screen
so i have been watching more movies like
that recently do you have a favorite
animal movie
no i don't not everyone does
so you mentioned you were married how
long have you and your husband been
together
a few years now that's great
my friend and his wife actually just got
married it was beautiful
making sure the user feels understood is
crucial to chatbot's success
many users will immediately exit a
conversation as soon as the bot gives a
clear sign of misunderstanding or
ignoring the user input obviously
improving nlu models is a necessary
effort to address this challenge
however another piece of the puzzle is
to make sure a chatbot meets user
expectations regarding common sense
world knowledge
for example the coven 19 outbreak
happened right in the middle of the
competition
and at certain points it seemed to be
the only thing on users minds
it therefore became crucial that our bot
could adequately speak about the
pandemic if it was to appear like an
intelligent being
the line graph on the left shows a
quasi-experimental result
where you see the average user rating
over time before versus
after adding a dedicated topic about the
coronavirus
adding this topic had a huge positive
impact which makes sense based on the
demand we observed
of people wanting to talk about the
coronavirus even before we had that
topic in place
the right hand graph is another result
with a similar theme
the red line shows the date of april
fool's day where we saw a spike in the
user rating concurrent with an update
that added a small interaction about
april fools
to the beginning of amaris conversation
flow throughout the competition
we noticed many cases like this where
events in the common public awareness
would alter people's expectations when
talking to the bots
being able to talk about these events
gives the conversation a sense of shared
experience
improving the bot's relatability and
perceived competence
speaking of shared experience we notice
while developing emra that it's pretty
difficult to make experience related
conversation
if the chatbot doesn't have any
experiences of its own to share
reciprocity is a major characteristic of
human conversation
and people can be genuinely curious
about the chatbots they
talk to and ask a lot of questions so we
did our best to develop emra as a
character in her own right
with opinions on almost everything she
asks users about
and also stories that she can share with
people about her own life
we facilitated this by giving her a
backstory where she's a student living
in a virtual world
and we saw this approach improve
conversation variety
it seemed a lot more natural than making
the entire conversation about the user
here's sarah demoing some of emra's
personality and character
i hope when i start working i'm doing
something i like most of the time
i always hear about people getting stuck
in a job they hate and that is scary to
me
yeah you should definitely try to avoid
doing that
aha this is a fun question when you were
younger
what did you want to be when you grew up
i always had this dream of like becoming
a paramedic
i think that's a good dream what changed
well i took a programming class in high
school and i really just discovered that
i liked working with technology and
computers a lot more
for sure it seems like everything
changes when you get older
it's silly but when i was only a few
months old i wanted to be an astronaut
wait really why
i think i just thought it would be cool
to explore space
i didn't know yet that there's no such
thing as outer space in my virtual world
i mean yeah that would make it pretty
hard to be an astronaut
for sure do you think it would be cool
to be an astronaut
i mean my sister thinks it would be cool
but i'm not so sure
so do you get along with your sister
wait i want to know do you have any
siblings
i actually don't have any siblings my
parents have just created me so far
what about the other social bots aren't
they kind of your siblings
well the other bots in this competition
aren't really my siblings
they aren't created by my family
do you wish that you had any siblings
yeah i would like to have an older
sister someone who i can look to for
advice and to do fun things with
yeah that would be cool wouldn't it
before we conclude the video here's one
more interesting result that
demonstrates the importance of user
psychology
when developing an experience oriented
chatbot
we saw at the beginning of the
presentation that adding experience
oriented conversation
has a positive impact on user rating
since we were in the middle of a
competition
we wanted to optimize this effect on our
user score by pushing all of the
experience oriented topics to the
beginning of amorous conversation flow
this actually had an unexpected and sort
of disastrous effect on our user score
you can see this quasi-experiment in the
line graph where the
red line marks a system update where we
put the most experience oriented topics
at the beginning of emra's conversation
on the date shown by the blue line we
made a second update where the only
major change was to simply alter the
order in which he introduced topics we
constrained our topic transitions so
that emira always started with an
opinion-oriented topic first
then transitioned to an
experience-oriented topic afterward
this simple reordering had one of the
most dramatic positive effects on our
user score that we had seen
we believe that the likely explanation
for this is people felt emerald was
getting too personal too early on
when we had the experience oriented
topics at the beginning of the
conversation
even though people were most engaged by
the experience oriented topics
once they had made some less personal
small talk this result suggests the
importance of understanding user
psychology when designing conversational
ai
one of emra's strongest design elements
turned out to be extremely sensitive to
these ordering effects
and we would guess that this was not an
isolated incident
i think most people can see the vast
potential of conversational ai
and how this potential is being
increasingly realized year after year
especially in recent times
emera contributes to this progress by
showing the potential of
designing chat bots that focus more on
the human aspects of conversation
people seem to find experience oriented
conversation more engaging
and our chatbot is a testament to the
idea that a bot doesn't need to be able
to answer
questions about a large number of facts
in order to interest people
with this chapter of our work concluded
we had emory have an
ongoing effort to improve the
fundamental technology behind amara
our future work is especially focused on
making amorous interactions scalable to
new domains
and continuing to improve her natural
language understanding to make
interactions
truly open domain and mixed initiative
thank you for watching
hi i'm abigail c i'm washington
and today we're going to tell you about
our alexa prize chat bots
and um the talk is called neural
generation
meets real people towards emotionally
engaging mixed initiative conversations
this is joint work with lots of other
wonderful people on the
stanford alex price team
so first to give you some context on the
competition the alexa prize is a
competition to advance conversational ai
and this year there were 10 university
teams who built chat bots for about nine
months
us alexa users can say let's chat and
then they get rooted to a random chatbot
who they talk to
in english for a while and then at the
end of the conversation the user gives a
rating from one to five
at the end of the development period
rbot had an average customer rating of
3.6 out of five
and then in the finals we won second
place based on several conversations
which were rated
by expert judges so one note is that in
this presentation
none of the conversation examples that
you see are from real user conversations
to protect their privacy
our chat bot is called chirpy cardinal
so cardinal is a reference both to
cardinal red which is the stanford color
and the cardinal bird so the idea if you
want to have a chirpy
upbeat positive personality
so our motivation in designing chubby
cardinal
is we noticed that there were four
common problems with many existing
social bots
the first problem is that they have too
little user initiative
so that means that the user is mostly
stuck being passive a kind of passenger
choosing options in the bots quite rigid
dialogue trees
this means that the user can't really
choose what they want to talk about
the second problem is a lot of social
bots can only chat about a narrow range
of topics
so the bot has these dialogue trees
which are pre-prepared for a small range
of popular topics
but this means that they can't really
talk about users own interests which
might be quite diverse and quite unusual
thirdly a lot of social bots can provide
information but they can't provide it
conversationally
so for example you might provide an
interesting fact such as on average
every adult human body contains two to
six pounds of bacteria
but a more conversational human-like way
to say that would be
did you know that your body contains two
to six pounds of bacteria it's kind of
disturbing huh
lastly we found that a lot of social
bots don't show enough interest or
empathy for the user's own personal
experiences and emotions so if the bot
is mostly spending their time talking
about external topics
that could be informational but it feels
kind of impersonal
so we find that these can be problems
that mean users feel less engaged in the
chatbot
so our user centered design goals for
cherby cardinal
are that we want to allow the user to
drive the conversation
the user needs to be able to choose
their own topics and the bot needs to be
able to flexibly switch topics according
to what the user is interested in
secondly we want our bot to be able to
chat about any topic
so whatever the user's unusual interests
are
we want to be able to chat knowledgeably
about it
thirdly we want to be able to provide
information conversationally so when
we're telling the users of information
we want to use naturalistic phrasing
and then be able to discuss further with
them using questions and opinions
lastly we want to engage empathetically
with users everyday experiences and
emotions
so we want to show interest in how the
user is feeling and what they're
experiencing
and ask them questions and share our own
similar experiences
so we find that these are design goals
that overall lead to more engaged users
so next i'm going to give you an
overview of how our system works
on the right we have an overview diagram
there's a lot going on here so i'm going
to go through each part individually
so overall our bot is built on top of
the cobot framework which is supplied by
the amazon team
and it's deployed on aws so each turn
starts with the user's utterance
they speak their utterance and then it's
transcribed by the alexa asr system
the transcription which we get has no
case or punctuation
so for example the user might say um
yeah i have a cat her name is misty
but it comes out without any full stops
you know no segmentation
and no capsule letters either
next we have the nlp pipeline so this is
a sequence of modules that annotate the
user's utterance
so we use stanford core llp and this
provides several standard nlp
services such as part of speech tagging
parsing etc
next we have an entity linker and this
identifies entities which the user is
mentioning
and it links it to the corresponding
wikipedia articles so for example if the
user says i live in boulder with my
parents
then we figure out that boulder probably
means boulder colorado
we also have a dialogue act classifier
so this figures out what is the dialogue
act of the user's utterance
so for example if the user says i think
it's kind of overrated
then that's an opinion if the user asks
do you have any family
then that's an open question in the
personal category
about the bot
next after the mlp pipeline we have the
dialog manager
the dialogue manager is in charge of
tracking which topics we're discussing
with the user
so at any point in the conversation we
have at most one
current entity that is under discussion
on sometimes there might be no current
entity for example if we're just saying
hello or goodbye or maybe we're talking
about some personal topic about the user
but at other times there can be one
entity that we're talking about
and this entity can be any wikipedia
article on all of english language
wikipedia so this helps us
achieve our design goal number two chat
about any topic
because wikipedia has a lot of articles
on a lot of obscure topics so we're able
to talk about a lot of things
in particular we have a navigational
intent classifier
so this uses some reg x's to identify if
the user is trying to navigate towards
or away from some topic
so for example if the user says do you
know anything about origami then that's
a positive navigational intent where
they want to talk about
origami and if they say could we change
the subject
then this is a negative navigational
intent saying that they don't want to
talk about whatever the current topic is
so here we are trying to allow the user
to drive the conversation by paying
attention
to what they want to talk about and
don't want to talk about
next we have an entity tracker so this
module determines what is the new
current entity
after processing the user's utterance so
using
uh the output of the entity linker and
the navigational intent classifier we
figure out what is the new entity the
new wikipedia article that we're talking
about
so here for example if the bot says i
love pandas they're so cute
then at that point the current entity is
the panda but if the user says but slots
the cuter
then now the current entity becomes the
sloth because these are showing that
they're more interested in sloths
next we have our response generators
these are modules and each one has
different conversational abilities so on
each turn we run all of the response
generators in parallel
each response generator can produce a
response
or none along with a priority so here's
an example
suppose the bot just said what are you
up to today
and right now one of the response
generators the neural chat one is
talking
and the user responds just playing some
animal crossing
so now we get all of our response
generators to generate a response
so in this example our opinion response
generator is able to give an opinion
about animal crossing saying that they
like it
the wikipedia response generator is able
to give some interesting
facts about animal crossing from the
wikipedia article
the neural chat which is a
neurogenerative model has a response
it's not as good because it doesn't
really understand what animal crossing
is
it says i love animals and then we have
our fallback response generator which
always just gives the same scripted
fallback response saying i'm not sure
how to respond to that
and then we might have some other
response generators that don't give a
response because their ability is not
relevant in this scenario
so you'll see that each response
generator also gives a priority along
with its response
so here the neural chat response
generator has used the priority week
continue
so this means that it can continue to
talk to the user
but it's a weak response because it
doesn't really understand what the
entity is
whereas the opinion and wiki response
generators can give a can start priority
to indicate that they could take over
the conversation at this point because
they know
something interesting about animal
crossing the fallback response generator
has its own priority which is lowest
meaning it only gets used if we have
nothing else
so next we choose one of the responses
of the several that we got
using the priority ranking module so
this just uses the highest priority
response with a tiebreaker if necessary
and then after that the entity tracker
updates the current entity if that's
necessary
so here here we might have chosen the
opinion response and now the new current
entity is animal crossing
so overall this priority system allows a
response generator to detect when its
ability is applicable to the user's
utterance
and then interject to respond like in
this example the opinion response
generator
took over control to give the
interesting opinion about animal
crossing
so this allows us to achieve our design
goal number one of being able to
flexibly switch topics
following the user's initiative the user
wants to talk about animal crossing so
we've followed them in this conversation
lastly once we've got our response we
might find that we need a different
response generator to add a prompt to
take the conversation forward
so as an example let's say the user has
criticized us because we've messed up
they say you're not very smart so we
have a response generator that's
dedicated to responding to these
criticisms we say sorry i'm trying to
get better
but we need something else in our bot
utterance to kind of take the
conversation in a new direction
so here we have a different response
generator the one that talks about music
to just start a new conversation on a
new topic saying do you play any musical
instruments
so after all of this we have our
complete boss utterance which might just
be a response or it might be a response
with a prompt added
so lastly our entire bot response is
spoken to the user
using the alexa's text-to-speech
software
and from the time when the user finishes
talking to we giving
we are giving our bot response that
medium time is just about
half a second and over 90 of responses
are two seconds or slower
and we find that if we respond in slower
than two seconds
then this feels pretty noticeably
awkward to the user so latency is pretty
important
so now i'm going to tell you a bit more
about the nlp pipeline in some more
detail
i mentioned earlier the dialogue acts
classifier so here we use a model that's
trained on the mydas
dialogue dataset which was collected by
another alexa price team
surprisingly we found that it didn't
actually work very well out of the box
so we're finding that even for really
similar domains two different other
express bots domain shift is quite a big
problem
but we did find that if we add our own
hand label training data
then this improved the performance quite
a lot
i also mentioned an entity linker so
here's how it works
first we collect anchor text statistics
for all wikipedia entities
so this is we look at each wikipedia
article and see
what kind of texts are used in the
hyperlinks to that article on wikipedia
so for example the entity barack obama
has anchor texts like barack obama
obama president obama etc
so let's suppose we have a user
utterance where the user just says i
shopped at banana republic today
what we do is we look through their
utterance and find potential entity
links by matching to
anchor texts on wikipedia so here we're
noticing that banana republic
might be the clothing store or it might
be the political science concept
and there's of course the fruit banana
etc
so how do we score these different
potential entities and figure out which
ones are more likely to be real links
so we have um a score for each user
utterance span to the potential entity
and this formula is saying that
uh if the entity is popular on wikipedia
it has lots of page views people are
reading it a lot
then that's more likely and then also if
the span
is likely to be a text that refers to
that entity
then it's more likely to be a link so in
our example
this means that we probably find that
banana republic is more likely to be the
clothing store
than the political science concept
probably because more people are reading
the wikipedia article about the clothing
store
we have another problem which is that
the automatic speech recognition service
does sometimes make some errors
so for example if the transcription says
i watch
for the ferrari then that seems like an
error the user's probably talking about
the movie forward
v ferrari so the problem with our system
here is that our scoring function is
going to assign a zero score to this
because there are no examples on
wikipedia where anyone wrote the text
for v ferrari and then linked that to
the movie
so the way we fix this is we take the
user's utterance and then we represent
it phonetically
and then we do a kind of fuzzy matching
to find what are some anchor texts that
have
a similar phonetic representation and
then this enables us to potentially
match to the correct movie
so next we're going to tell you a bit
more about our response generators
so we have about um 18 response
generators in the bot
but we're only going to tell you about
the few most important ones in this
presentation
so i mentioned earlier the neural chat
response generator and this uses a
neural generative model
to discuss the user's personal
experiences and emotions so here we're
trying to achieve our design goal number
four that is showing empathy for the
user's feelings and experiences
so we start off by asking a handwritten
start question so an example of this is
we ask how are you feeling today
and then after this we chat back and
forth with the user and all the
subsequent turns from the bot
are generated by a gpt2 media model
which we fine-tuned on the empathetic
dialogues data set
so here we ask how's the user feeling
they say kind of bored this was a more
common response
due to the pandemic and you know we show
some empathy and ask why they're bored
and they say they're stuck inside and we
suggest maybe you could go outside
and so on so we find that there are some
problems we encounter with this model so
some of the biggest problems are
we find it difficult to kind of ask
questions that make sense so sometimes
the model asks redundant questions
like if the user says i'm making soup
for lunch then we might say what are you
having for lunch and
we've already got that information
another example is we make
unfounded assumptions uh that the uh
user didn't
provide that information so for example
if the user says i played frisbee today
and we say i'm glad to hear you had fun
playing frisbee with your dog but that's
a hallucination we never
um the user never said anything about a
dog
so we find that to avoid derailing the
conversation uh we typically keep these
conversations pretty short
they're usually only about three
utterance pairs because if it goes on
for too long then the bot's quite likely
to say one of these questions it doesn't
make sense
and then that derails the conversation
the problem is that this limits the
conversational depth we're unable to
talk about anything in a lot of detail
if
we can only go for about three times
so i mentioned that we asked the users
about how they're feeling
we find that the neural model works a
lot better if the users give
longer more contentful references but
the problem is that sometimes users just
say i'm fine or okay or something very
short and then that makes it hard for us
to find something interesting to stay
back
so we tried experimenting with preceding
our question
how are you feeling today by first the
bot telling the user
about its own feelings so we might try
saying i'm feeling pretty positive today
or i'm feeling kind of down lately
before asking the user how they're
feeling
we also tried getting the bot to share a
personal anecdote before asking
so we might say something positive about
going for a walk and how it felt good
or it might say something negative about
why they're feeling down missing their
friends finding it hard to focus
and again this was inspired by the
pandemic
so interestingly we found that users
give longer responses
when the bot first shares its own
emotions
and strangely we found if the bot
expresses that it's feeling down
then this led to longer user responses
than if the bot said they were feeling
positive
this might be because if we say we're
feeling down it kind of creates an
atmosphere of more real honesty
so the users feel more able to share
their own feelings
we also found that if the bot includes
the personal anecdote that also leads to
longer user responses
next i'll explain the wiki rg
so to support our goal of high coverage
world knowledge
the wiki rg uses wikipedia articles as
grounding
to discuss any entity that interests the
user
our goal is to allow the user to
conversationally discover interesting
information about any entity
so for example in this case the
user the key rg first
remembers that the user had mentioned
neo and then back references neo from an
earlier conversation with a prompt
uh then in the next turn uh vicky
rg realizes that neo is a specific
kind of entity and gives an open-ended
question
which is specific to fictional
characters these questions are designed
to elicit contentful user responses
which can then be matched to specific
sentences
in the wikipedia article using tfidf
overlap
and in the final return the
response generator gives a
conversationally styled response
and then switches to talking about more
fears
apart from this as abby mentioned
previously there are
other cases for instance we talk about
fun facts that we escaped from
today i learned something as well
one of our design goals was to provide
information conversationally
and this response generator
is a test bed for our conversational
paraphrasing system
this system uh has many goals but
the few important ones are one to sort
of summarize the
knowledge snippet that you want to
introduce in the conversation uh to
stylize it so that
the words and the phrasing that is used
is much more colloquial than
that is in wikipedia and then to also
maintain conversational flow
referencing what the user had just said
and then providing a path forward for
the conversation
so given the truncated conversational
history
uh and some knowledge context as input
our conversational paraphrasing model
outputs a
natural surrounding paraphrase uh given
of the knowledge context so
in this case there's a long sentence
about how new and trinity successfully
rescue morpheus
and uh from heavily armed guards and so
on
and so it's nicely paraphrased together
um
into how the bot liked something about
the movie
and then it continues with some other
open-ended questions the challenges that
we face with this system is
that sometimes it had factually not
inaccuracies while copying
over content from the knowledge snippets
on the other hand
sometimes it would do verbatim copying
and we kind of want to avoid that
because that doesn't have a
conversational styling to it
next we talk about opinion rg so
a design goal number four was that we
want to show interest in the users
feelings and experiences
exchanging opinions is a core part of
social chit chat it forms a stronger
sense of personality and makes our bot
seem more relatable
so how it is important that our bot can
also express its opinions
the opinion rg's goal is to listen to
users opinion on certain topics and then
reciprocate with
for its own opinions um on these topics
we collect such opinions both positive
and negative opinions by querying a
twitter stream
using a regex which collects tweets of
the form i love or hate
a certain topic because of a certain
reason
these the topic and reason can be any
text we collected over 900 000 tweets
out of which we manually white listed
around a thousand reasons
across 100 popular topics
we uh to avoid speaking inappropriately
about sensitive topics we only white
list
uncontroversial entities such as animals
foods everyday experiences such as
working from home
being sick etc we also ensured that all
the reasons including negative ones are
inoffensive and good spirited
so for example here we see that the user
says i love cats
and then our bot first understands user
sentiment
and then chooses to disagree with the
user and going on to ask their
reason uh for why they like gets and
then
in the next one interestingly uh opinion
our response generator emulates a change
of mind
saying a reason why they might also like
cats
so this kind of leads us to
the next part of it which is whether to
agree or to disagree with the user
disagree disagreement is an unavoidable
part of human human conversations and we
hypothesize that occasional disagreement
is necessary
in order for our bot to have a
convincing and individual personality
so we test this using three policies one
is always agree where they
we always agree with the user sentiment
second is listen first disagree
where we first listen to the user's
reason but then disagree with it
and then finally we have convinced agree
where we first disagree with user
sentiment but then change the opinion
after listening to the user's reason
so to evaluate this we ask the user
would you like to continue sharing
opinions
and if they say yes then that's a good
sign
so comparing these three policies we see
that
always agree has a continuation rate of
0.58
and between the two strategies that
disagree uh
convinced agree still maintains that
continuation rate whereas listen first
disagree uh
reduces the continuation rate so it goes
on to say that disagreeing in a right
way
in the sense of convinced agreed
actually doesn't reduce engagement
but but it brings variety to the table
um and also surprises the user in a nice
way
so the final response generator i want
to talk about is
offensive user users sometimes give
offensive or critical utterances
and our goal is to redirect the user
from making a
more offensive comments towards the
topics that the bot can discuss
so for example sometimes the user some
users say
i want to talk about sex and we sort of
want to handle this
we tried many strategies and
they are all listed here the way we
evaluate these strategies
is to look at the reoffense rate which
is is
how likely is it that the user will have
another offensive turn
after our intervention to explain the
strategies a bit more there are four
main categories
one is why which is we ask the user why
did you say that
the next one is avoidance where we say i
would rather not talk about that
and then we have a counter where we say
something like this is a very suggestive
thing to say i don't think we should be
talking about that
and then finally we have an empathetic
strategy where we say
if i could talk about it i would but i
really couldn't sorry to disappoint
so um beyond this we tried two more
add-ons to it
so first i'll explain the prompt where
uh we add the text in blue
which is suggesting a new topic to go on
to
and then the other strategy is we refer
to the user by name
um so we say why did you see that peter
and so on
now to understand the effects of all of
these strategies
let's first look at what happens when we
uh
take like when we refer to the user by
name so we see that
um for avoidance strategies name
works really well and the reoffense rate
reduces
drastically whereas when we ask why then
it actually increases a bit
we believe that we are actually we might
be motivating the user to defend
themselves which prolongs the offensive
conversation and especially when we ask
them by name
and finally uh out of the four major
strategies that i've introduced to you
first
we found out that avoidance seemed to be
the most
effective in reducing the reoffense rate
and in particular avoidance with name
and prompt
was the most effective out of everything
okay moving on to some analysis and
discussion of our social work
first uh let's have a quick look at user
engagement and trends
so on the y-axis you would know you'll
notice that we have rating
and on the x-axis we have various
metrics of user engagement
so we observe that as the number of
turns increases
the rating keeps going up up until a
certain point after which it reduces
slightly
we believe that this might be because um
of the limitations in content of our bot
and after a certain while it probably
just gets more repetitive and users
don't like it as much
and secondly we um
we thought that a longer user utterance
length
is more indicative of a more satisfied
user
but it turns out that the pattern is not
that clear and
mostly it's flat uh we think that this
might be because of
our inability to handle long user
utterances
in a meaningful way and it reflects more
a limitation of a robot
than of general ways in which people
like talking to bots
we also do some analysis of initiative
using dialog x so if you remember dialog
goal uh sorry design goal 1
we want the user to drive the
conversation and
giving the user more initiative is how
we sort of analyze it
so on the x axis sorry on the right side
you can see
um regression coefficients of various
dialogue acts
versus rating so these are the dialogue
acts that we got from our
dialogue act classifier um
so first of all we believe that
questions indicate
high user initiative and if you look at
questions
uh in this figure we see that for yes no
questions
uh it is positively associated with
higher ratings whereas it's not as clear
for open question personal and open
question factual
which typically have longer answers we
think that this might be because
of our inability to handle these open
questions appropriately and in the
future perhaps doing it better
would be a would improve user initiative
quite a bit
secondly we look at statements and
opinions which we think
are medium user initiative this is
because
sometimes uh users can volunteer new
pieces of information
which is indicative of how much
initiative they are trying to take we
see that
both of these dialogue acts have a
positive correlation
with rating and finally we look at
answers
so we believe that answers are typically
two questions
which the ball asked and they indicate
lower user initiative so we see that
positive and negative answers are
correlated positively
and negatively respectively with the
rating
and we believe that that's just because
um positive answers are more reflective
of the times we understood the user
right
and suggested the right topic whereas
negative answers is quite the opposite
finally other answers are also slightly
lower
in correlation with rating
and then we look at broad topical
coverage so if you remember our design
goal 2
we want to talk about any topic chat
about any topic
and so in this diagram uh we see
on the x-axis different ranges of page
views
for different entities which are
essentially wikipedia articles
and we take it as a proxy for different
popularity levels
and on the y-axis you see the percentage
of conversations which include entities
from one of these bins so what we see is
that the percentage of conversations in
which users initiated the discussion of
entities
with lower page views is quite
significant
in particular 33 percent of
conversations had at least
one entity with less than 8 000 page
views
moreover conversations with rare
entities were rated better
an average of 3.88 compared to those
without
and uh in general we saw that we had
seven and a half distinct entities on
average
per conversation finally um as
to round up the analysis uh we look at
rg performance
and first to uh the first thing we
notice is that
good rg's are better than bad arches
so yeah but then interestingly we also
see that
scripted rg's are still performing
slightly better
than open-ended rgs despite our attempts
to
improve open-art ended rg's in quality
and finally we see that
neural fallback which is a replacement
for fallback
uh improves the um
rating of the conversations in general
all right so for discussion and future
work
uh first up is full stack nlp so most
nlp research focuses on self-contained
tasks
however an open domain social bot is by
no means a self-contained task
our social bot is a tapestry of many
such components requiring a deep
understanding of each component and how
they should work together
a setting we call full stack nlp often
the inputs and outputs to these
components are interdependent which
leads to cascading errors
while we have made many design choices
which delay hard decisions in the
pipeline
the next avenues for advancing state of
the art would be to research
uh do to do research on models which
perform these tasks
jointly and methods which enable
training over multiple interdependent
tasks
with only a small amount of joint
supervision
next is the issue of domain shift as a
recurring problem we found that many
existing nlp resources
didn't well work well out of the box the
main reason for this is that the
training data for these resources is
misaligned with our setting
however a deeper reason is that the
constantly changing nature of dialogue
agents
also affects it even for an extremely
related resource domain shift was a
problem
and recent advances in online learning
and meta learning
could provide useful long-term solutions
for this
problem next is
the issue of conflicting topics and user
intimacy
so what human conversations are
fundamentally different
to human human conversations users can
be adversarial
and deliberately test the board's
boundaries as as social work designers
we would like to avoid controversies
so we apply strict but overly simplistic
methods to block off sensitive topics
however this rules out sincere
conversation about difficult topics
we observed that users are actually
quite resilient to conflict
and can find disagreement stimulating we
also found out that emotional intimacy
is reciprocal users are more inclined to
share their feelings after the bot has
shared its own
so going forward we should continue to
take seriously the dangers of speaking
inappropriately
but also keep in mind the cost to
engagement and to intimacy
of not engaging in difficult topics
and finally as part of our goal to
support user initiative
we focused on asking the users to find
out which topics interested them
however this puts pressure on the user
to think of a response especially given
the time constraints of alexa devices
thus we found that our attempts to let
the user take more initiative
unfortunately led to decision fatigue
separately
our ability to support user initiative
was limited by our ability to answer
follow-up questions
and to correctly understand long user
returns on balance we found that
asking the user open-ended questions
about interesting topics was a good
strategy
easier to handle than spontaneous user
questions and less pressuring than
asking the users to name topics
we see an opportunity for future work to
build systems which listen more to the
user's knowledge
rather than only providing knowledge
so this concludes our presentation um
you can go online and check out our
technical article
neural generation meets real people for
more details
thanks
hi my name is jan peco and together with
my colleagues peter marek and jacob
conrad
we would like to present our social bot
called alquest 2.
our boat placed third in the recent alex
surprise grand challenge three
and we won the second prize during both
of the previous years
of the competition our presentation
starts with a brief history that led us
to the ideas for the current board
after that we will describe the most
relevant parts of the system too
okay let's do it i'll start with the
evolution of our quest bot
through the years of the competition
this brief description gives you an
insight into the system goals and how it
was evolving based on the previous
experience
and what is the primary motivation of
this year's contribution
during the first year of alexa price
competition we quickly discovered
that the bot could not be created in an
end to end way
therefore we designed dialog structures
suitable for each topic
these structures were implemented as
state automata
guiding a user through the conversation
as we evaluated the user experience it
showed that conversations are too
scripted
and don't allow much flexibility
moreover
they were hard to maintain
based on these findings we redesigned
our board
during the second year of the
competition
we introduced smaller graph structures
each covering only a small piece
of each topic each structure has its own
dialog management model trained on the
data generated using the design graph
structures
we group these structures into so-called
topic nodes allowing more
flexibility during the conversation this
approach
works very well for cooperative users
but
still lacks the ability to handle
unexpected utterances
to address the users who want to drive
conversation in a proactive way as well
as the long tail topics
we introduce a colonization knowledge
graph with atomic dialogue structures
this year
in the next slides we will describe how
to use the knowledge graph to enhance
the system
and provide more engaging conversations
the conversational knowledge graph is
meant to contain only information
about the topics the bot is capable of
talking about
for this purpose we design a custom
ontology inspired schema.org
and ev ontology these ontologies however
cover only the factual information about
the entities
to make it more conversational we
enriched the ontology by the user and
bought notes
representing both participants of the
colonization
and additionally by the preference
relations
we can then easily add connections
between bot or user to the specific
entity
to capture relationship mentioned in the
conversation
now we have the ontology but we need
data to fill the knowledge graph with
we use snapshot of the wiki data to
initialize the graph
it allows the bot to use plenty of real
world factoid information in the
conversations with the users
using the standard database such as
wikidata also
allows us to link entities mentioned in
the attendances to the
database ids using existing tools
additionally we needed to implement a
custom entity linking mechanism only for
our custom data which are not included
in wikidata
moreover we are continuously enriching
the static data by the dynamic content
such as new movies etc
the key points in the dialog are the
users and bot nodes
in most of the dialog turns the bot
works with one of these nodes
for example if user says i like matrix
we want to link i to the user node in
addition to a matrix being mapped to the
movie matrix in the knowledge graph
now we have user entity matrix entity
and property likes the board then stores
the fact in the knowledge graph
and it is ready to work with it in the
upcoming conversations
we focus primarily on the preferences
based relations between entities
and the user such as like love
dislike hate as favorite as opinion
etc the preferences of the bot are
manually pre-filled
for the most discussed entities if a
user asks a question regarding an
unknown preference the bot can reply
with a generic answer additionally we
can
add the most ask preferences based on
the logs
and raise the preferences most commonly
mentioned by users
we also use the knowledge graph to
generate training data
for new modules to do so we have the
knowledge graph annotated with template
sentences
using custom annotation properties the
annotation properties
are assigned to a relation connecting
two entities
each relation has domain and range
entity
that defines a direction of the relation
the annotation property describes the
sentence in nature language that can be
expressed using the corresponding
relation
the domain and range entities are mask
in the annotation property
the annotation properties are also
divided based on the dialogue act
for example for the property likes and
the
dialogue act statement we want to have
sentence domain domain likes range and
analogically
for the question the sentence would be
does domain-like
range and combining these atomic
structures
we are able to create more complex
utterances
and it is important to note that the
data can be used to train both
understanding and generative models
we observed during the previous
installment of alexa price competition
that a noticeable part of users messages
had the following structure
yes i like movie what is your favorite
song or
do you like sports because i do or
let's switch the topic i would like to
chat about movies
as we can see those messages consist of
two parts
we call these parts segments those
segments have different meanings
and intents thus it's not enough to
handle them together
as one message we have to process each
sub segment
because there might be some new
information that we can store
into a conversational knowledge graph or
some questions we have to handle
we came up with the idea of action to be
able to process
all segments an action is an atomic unit
which takes the role in the processing
of segment
action contains nau annotations and
links to the adjacency pair
which produces an answer there are
multiple types
of actions action contains following
nlu annotations an entity
and property of conversational knowledge
graph
and dialog act the entity tells us
what the user is talking about in the
question
what is the capital of czech republic we
recognize the entity czech republic
which we link into our knowledge graph
we now know all the information we have
stored about the czech republic
which we can use in the dialogue
property of conversational knowledge
graph specifies
which property user is talking about
in the question what is the capital of
czech republic
we know that the user is talking about
property
capital off we can look into the
conversational knowledge graph now
we can find that the property capital
off
going from the entity czech republic is
prague and we can use it to form an
answer we can read information from the
conversational knowledge graph
as well as store information into it too
dialogue act is the last nlu annotation
stored in action dialogue act tells
us whether the user asks an open
question like
what is the capital of czech republic
yes no question
like do you like sports or
if the user informs us about some fact
like
i have a sister if a user
asks a question we read from the
conversational knowledge graph
if the user informs us we store
information
into it instead also
we respond differently to different
dialogue acts
there will be a different answer to open
and yes no questions
for example thus dialog act
determines whether we will use read or
write operation
on the conversational knowledge graph
and the type of response
we produce
now that we have an action containing
entity alquist
property favorite movie and dialogue act
open question we know that we should
find
alquist's favorite movie in the
conversational knowledge graph
furthermore we use a particular
adjacency pair to form a response
however how do we create an action how
do we know
how many we will need
we use segmentation to determine how
many actions
we will need to process the user's
message
segmentation takes the output of
automatic speaker recognition
and split it into segments
for example yes io export do like music
is split into two segments yes
i like sport and do you like music
we have to keep in mind that the problem
of segmentation
is not as easy as splitting the input
according to punctuation
some of the asr systems produce sequence
of words
without any punctuation marks once we
have segments
we create action for each and we run
nlu algorithms to obtain entities
properties
and dialogue acts for each action
independently
thus thanks to the segmentation we know
how to split into messages into actions
which we process independently
however that is not all one of the big
problems of any conversational
application
is the noisy output of asr
typically when we do not have clear asr
output
llu components make errors that further
propagate
up to the point that the final response
does not make any sense
the authors of asr try to fight this
problem
by providing several recognition
hypotheses
together with their confidence from
which we can choose
however there is a problem how do we
pick the right hypothesis
we came up with the solution which
utilizes the actions
this first step of our solution is to
run the segmentation
on all hypotheses of asr
in the second step we create action for
each segment
in each hypothesis in the last step
we select the best asr hypothesis based
on the combined score of
asr confidence and scores of an action
of that particular asr hypothesis
we process only actions which are part
of the asr hypothesis
which we select based on the score
how do we calculate the asr hypothesis
score
the first part is the confidence of the
asr hypothesis itself
the second part is the combined score of
all actions
present in the asr hypothesis how do we
calculate the score for
action we have entity property
and dialogue annotations in each action
a machine learning algorithm typically
produces these annotations
together with its confidence we can use
this confidence scores combine them and
calculate the score
for the action now that we have asr
hypothesis confidences
and scores for all actions we can
calculate the score of all asr
hypotheses
and pick the best one for further
processing
the idea behind this is that the best
asr hypothesis
will lead to the most confident nlu
annotations
in all its actions
in reality the processing of nlu
annotations
is time consuming we process only the
top and
asr hypothesis for this reason moreover
some of the scores of actions are very
low we decided to filter such
actions based on the threshold thus
we do not send them all for further
processing
to recap the row of actions in allquist
we observed
that users are telling us many facts and
asking multiple questions
in a single message we split messages
into segments
for this reason each segment contains
one action
an action is an atomic unit which
contains
entity property and dialogue act and
maps it into an adjacency pair
which is responsible for the production
of response
moreover we also use actions to
determine the least noisy asr hypothesis
you have already heard the words
adjacency pair so let me now explain
what they are and why we decided to
integrate them to the core of our system
adjacency pairs are sequences of two
utterances
that are often present in the
conversation we define them as a pair of
utterances that have the following
properties
they are adjacent to one another one
another in the conversation
one follows immediately after another in
most cases
each of them is produced by a different
speaker
or in our case one is produced by the
bot and the other is produced by the
user
or vice versa they have the first part
and the second part
meaning that their order is not
interchangeable
the first part of the utterance often
requires a specific second part
or one of possible several second parts
an example of an adjacency pair can be
simple greeting greeting such as
the speaker a says good morning and the
speaker
b would answer morning or it can be a
question answered pair
the speaker a would say do you like
movies
and the speaker b would respond yes i do
chaining these pairs together can create
a naturally flowing conversation
we want our sub dialogues to be made of
one or several
adjacency pairs this way it is simpler
for us to predict
user responses due to adjacency pairs
often having expected specific types of
answers
first we wanted to test how prevalent
adjacency pairs are in conversation
to see how viable for building a
dialogue from them be
in the first place we analyzed all
conversations in the multiverse data set
for each entry in the conversation we
have noted the dialog
act of the entry and the dialog act of
the following entry as well
as noted who is currently speaking we
have then created a list of dialogue act
pairs
that fulfill all four previously
mentioned conditions
and we use them as adjacency power
candidates
the results show that as expected
the dialogues have the adjacency pair
structure
for example almost one four of
statements
made by one speaker are immediately
followed by some sort of minor
acknowledgement
by the second speaker or and the first
speaker
asks a w question this question is
in 59 of cases followed by a statement
usually the answer by the second speaker
these patterns correspond to adjacency
pairs as described previously
we aim to recreate a similar structure
of conversation within our system
where conversation consists of adjacency
pairs
that are then chained together to
provide an engaging and natural
conversation
we have defined a set of adjacency
groups
where each group contains a set of
similar adjacency pairs
with the same opening utterance but
different closing curtains
you can see these examples on the screen
there are 17 groups in total
and they are divided into two categories
user-initiated adjacency pairs
which consists of 13 groups and both
initiated adjacency pairs which consists
of four groups
when the system detects a user action
that corresponds to an adjacency pair
opening
it produces a closing action based on
the
detected adjacency per group using the
context of the conversation
and the information accessible in the
knowledge graph for example
when user asks the system do you like
california
which is a user post question the
question is positive it is a yes no
question outfit selects an
answer based on its profile in the
knowledge base and based on the
positive user yes no question adjacency
per group
so the answer can be for example
affirmative answer
or it can be a negative answer or always
can simply say that it doesn't know
which would be an inform unknown answer
alquist is also able to initiate
adjacency pairs
in the conversation it might ask
what would you like to talk about which
is a
what open positive question where it
expects do you
expect the user to either answer the
question with an inform answer
or say that the user doesn't know which
is an in-form unknown answer
if the user provides the closing
caterans for the adjacency pair
allquist updates the knowledge base
accordingly
otherwise it locks the unclosed
adjacency pair for statistical purposes
we aim to combine both of these
conversational patterns
into our conversation where the system
both closes the adjacency pair that was
initiated previously by the user
and also provides an opening statement
for a new adjacency pair to allow the
conversation to keep flowing
to achieve this we divide the bot
utterance into three parts
handle action that provides a closing
statement for the current adjacency pair
if any
then what we call a fun fact action
which aims to provide an additional
information about the current topic
either in the form of a fun fact
or a piece of information related to the
user or all quest
found in the knowledge graph and finally
forward action
which initiates a new adjacency pair an
example of this pattern of conversation
can be
user asks do you like california to
which the
aqueous bot would answer yes i do that
is a handle action
then it would continue i heard that san
diego california is known as the avocado
capital of the world
that would be a fun fact action
and finally our quest would add speaking
of do you like avocados
which would be a forward action to which
user can again
close the open adjacency pair by saying
yes i do
often when contextually appropriate
after closing the adjacency parameter
handle action
the old subdialog system can take over
and provide
fun fact and forward actions by
initiating a subdialog for the current
topic as well
finally let me summarize the main
improvements and innovations
of the alquest 2020 system based on
previous years of the competition
we have focused our efforts to improve
the experience for users who prefer to
be more proactive in the conversation
and like to take initiative while also
retaining the last year's subdialog
functionality
to do this we created a conversational
knowledge base
which with custom ontology focused on
knowledge about the user
and alquist we developed a system of
handling
user utterances by dividing a user
attracts into segments
and defining actions that each segment
represents to correctly handle
all parts of the user response
we described a set of adjacent zippers
frequently occurring in conversations
with our system
and directly connected them to actions
this allows us
to easily create more elaborate
conversational patterns
from elementary units while maintaining
the pace of requiration
with that i would i would like to thank
you
for your attention if you would like to
follow our journey going forward
you can find us on social media at
elquist ai
and you can find the links to the papers
that describe
our system either there or with the qr
code that is displayed on the screen
thank you
you